when American Explorer David Fairchild
travelled the world in the mid
nineteenth century he did more than send
back postcards he brought back the foods
of the world they're now the staples of
the American diet from avocados to
oranges to kale all were crops he
encountered abroad and helped introduce
to farmers back here at home his story
is told in the new book the food
Explorer the true Adventures of the
globe-trotting botanist who transformed
what America eats and we're joined by
author Daniel Stone Daniel good morning
good morning
tell us how you discovered david
fairchild rediscovered I should say and
his amazing story I grew up working on
and living near farms I love food I eat
food and I heard the story of this man
an adventurer botanist I had never heard
that title given to anyone
it's more I don't know that it has been
and this was 120 years ago that he lived
and he traveled all over the world in
search of crops novel foods like
avocados and dates and mangoes that
didn't exist here before you broke my
heart a little bit with this book Daniel
I'm a Florida girl and to find that
Florida oranges are not native to
Florida what know all citrus is native
to China and very few of the crops that
we eat are north american right apples
come from kazakhstan and citrus from
china and bananas from New Guinea our
foods came to this country like many of
our families did as immigrants and
brought here many of them by Fairchild
at the turn of the 20th century he left
Kansas at the age of 20 for a position
as a junior scientist flighting fighting
plant fungus for the Department of
Agriculture but this all kind of changed
when he met on an ocean liner he met a
millionaire who funded these expeditions
he was enormous ly lucky right you all
get we each get one major stroke of luck
early in our careers this was his he met
on a boat across the Atlantic a
fabulously wealthy millionaire named
Barbara Lathrop who funded his travels
and invested in him said I think you
have scientific promise here's $1,000
take it fuel your travels and Barbara
Lathrop was one of the early
philanthropist
to American food you know this book also
features diplomacy horticulture as
diplomacy from beer to cherry blossoms
tell me a little bit about that yeah
Fairchild went to almost every continent
in search of better seeds better breed
stock he goes to Bavaria in 1902 which
has the best hops the best beer in the
world and essentially diplomatically
acquires better hops he goes to Japan
the next year and sees the cherry
blossom trees and finds a way with the
white house to import and negotiate the
gift of the cherry blossom trees to
Washington DC so the cherry blossoms
Luisi in washington we owe to him yeah
he negotiated that exchange with the
with the approval of President Taft in
1912 what what else do we owe to him
Daniel mangoes he picked up 58 varieties
of mangoes types of watermelon seedless
grape varieties kale the Meyer lemon was
the acquisition of one of his teammates
Frank Meyer hops in in Bavaria and
certainly types of citrus in China all
the way to the Mediterranean you know
we're a country of immigrants I was so
fascinated to hear apparently so is our
food yeah the diversity of food from
different countries how has that helped
with what's put around the table in
America we are a hodgepodge everything
we eat came from a different part of the
world we haven't been here very long as
Americans early civilizations in Egypt
right the Aztecs have been around much
longer they were farming for centuries
for millennia and we are living very
much the lives of immigrants building a
country of not just people but culinary
meals that that reflect kind of our new
our newness to this land Daniel what was
it that the drove David Fairchild this
fascinating man he had two passions he
loved plants and he loved to travel and
this was very rare in the late 19th
century to travel around the world and
he found a way to fuel his his kind of
wanderlust and put it to good use you
know farmers were most of the labor
force in those days they were all
growing the same thing a lot of corn a
lot of we
mmm-hmm a lot of oats and no one was
making much money and so Fairchild put
his travels to to use Daniel stone
fascinating story fascinating book thank
you so much for being with us thanks for
having look is the food Explorer The
Adventures of the globe-trotting
botanist who transformed what America
eats